[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
this is day three of claudia drury's
testimony we're still on direct
examination and part of it is that it
keeps getting interrupted federal court
is delayed when the defendant is carted
out on a stretcher for the second time
and from therenow ceo to federal court
opening statements are presented in the
trial of ramesh sunny bawwani plus a six
million dollar fake jewelry scam the
profits from the sale counterfeit goods
is really lucrative how investigators
work to track down the counterfeit
kingpins but first the potential
sentence in this case is death the
latest developments in the case of the
doomsday duo law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
just days after an idaho judge rules the
so-called doomsday duo will be tried
together chad dabo's defense motions to
dismiss murder charges in the case
chad dabal and his wife laurie valo
dabel face charges in the deaths of
lori's two children j.j valo and tyler
wright as well as dave bell's first wife
tammy the pair were dubbed the doomsday
duo for a shared belief in the end of
days the couple was married in 2019 just
weeks after dave elle's wife
mysteriously died in her sleep and
valodebel's youngest children went
missing tammy dabel's body was later
exhumed and in june 2020 the remains of
jj and tyler were recovered on chad
davil's property since then there have
been questions surrounding valodeva's
ability to stand trial after she was
initially deemed incompetent the outcome
of a recent psychiatric evaluation has
not been released but a trial for the
couple is scheduled for early next year
at a hearing on wednesday chad dabo's
attorneys argued their client could not
face charges in the death of his first
wife
tammy
the potential sentence in this case is
death
the severity of this case in this court
uh addressed that in a prior decision
that you uh set forth and i believe that
was in your memorandum regarding the
venue and you cited that death is
different and the magnitude of the
charge judge is what's important here
and when you're considering the the
validity or the impartiality of a grand
jury proceeding judge you have to take
you have to take into consideration
the consequence it's a result of that
so there needs to be a higher scrutiny
and a higher review of the standards
that are set forth
right let's take a higher review of this
case joining us today is criminal
defense attorney adam conta and terry
austin adam it looks like the day bells
will be tried together is that the right
ruling and should chad's defense
attorneys have maybe push a little
harder to separate the cases
well i think the standard for whether
cases are tried together or not for most
judges is just essentially is the
evidence the same are the charges the
same and is it a waste of money
essentially in time if we try these
cases separately in this particular
instance the answer to all those
questions are yes the evidence is the
same for both of them pretty much the
charges are the same the facts are the
same so to try them separately would in
fact be a huge waste of time the caveat
here though is that we have no idea how
long laurie vallo stabel is going to be
found mentally unfit so yeah if i was
his attorneys i'd be screaming from the
rooftops like what are we doing here
judge this man has a right to trial he
has a right to have his case heard in
front of a jury and that is being
postponed indefinitely you can't just do
this to my client forever and
unfortunately that's what's going to
happen at least for the foreseeable
future yeah early next year is a pretty
long time to wait for trial terry the
trial is set to be heard in ada county
300 miles from fremont county does the
change of venue help find a jury
you know what brian it's going to be
very difficult to find a jury no matter
what county it is in whether it's
fremont whether it's madison whether
it's ada county which as you say is 300
miles away but i do think judge boyce
made the right decision here at least
there'll be some chance that you'll get
jurors who haven't heard of the case but
it's going to be a very small chance but
he also is preserving the fact that this
is not going to be an issue on appeal
the defendant obviously has this right
to have a fair trial and this will give
that opportunity to get those jurors who
might have not heard about the case
absolutely now while chad daybell and
lori valodebel's cases will remain tied
together the parents of the accused
oxford michigan high school shooter are
now being charged separately in a
pre-trial hearing this week a circuit
court appointed the pair different
attorneys jennifer and james crumbly
appeared in court briefly on tuesday
where judge sheryl matthews voiced
concern about a potential conflict of
interest should the couple retain the
same attorneys within the next two weeks
both jennifer and james crumbly will
meet with separate independent attorneys
right now they're due back in court on
april 5th both are charged with four
counts of involuntary manslaughter
following the shooting spree at oxford
high school last november
prosecutors say their 15 year old son
opened fire in the school killing four
students and injuring others he faces
charges of first-degree murder assault
with a deadly weapon and terrorism
in nevada investigators search for a
missing 18-year-old who they say was
kidnapped from her own vehicle officials
say
naomi irion was last seen on march 12
when she was abducted from a walmart
parking lot about 30 minutes from reno
nevada surveillance video shows a man
approaching irion's vehicle and later
driving off in her car investigators are
now calling for help to identify the
suspect and the vehicle of interest a
chevrolet 2500 year 2020 or newer at a
press conference this week irion's
family asked the public to come forward
with any new information
don't
post about it without talking to law
enforcement first
don't do anything
without talking to law enforcement first
this is life or death for my sister
life or death
i don't care if you think it's
insignificant or if you need other
people's approval you need no one's
approval
before calling law enforcement
this is life or death for
a beautiful
and
fun
and
amazing
sister
daughter
and friend
she was
she's sorry is
she
she's just starting
her adult life
if you have any information about
erion's whereabouts or the person of
interest please call the number on your
screen
still ahead on law and crime daily after
several delays the federal trial is now
underway for therino ceo ramesh sunny
bowani but first six million dollars
worth of fake jury seized in kentucky
how investigators tracked down the
criminals behind the scheme
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
millions of dollars worth of counterfeit
jewelry makes its way into the u.s each
year and recently cuss an agent seized
the cachet of watches and rings with
some high-end names law and crime's
ancient levy is here with what was
seized and where the fake goods are sold
brian think about a rolex watch you know
a lot of people may want one and turn to
the internet in search of one but it's
very possible what you're buying and
finding online could be fake now
recently customs and border protection
agencies in louisville kentucky came
across a shipment of fake watches
earrings and rings valued at 4.5 million
dollars a short time later they found
another 2 million dollars more of fake
jewelry and now these are photos of some
of those counterfeit items
counterfeiters sometimes use high-end
brands like rolex cardiac cartier and
louis vuitton
thomas mann who is the director of the
port of louisville says the counterfeit
jewelry is sold on sites like ebay and
craigslist and they are priced lower but
comparably to give the impression the
jewelry is real homely and security
investigators work to track the jewelry
to the original source
and they will actually work with our
overseas attaches to work with a foreign
country counterparts where the shipment
originated to try to shut down those
networks overseas they'll also look at
the constantine here in in the states
uh to uh affect the you know enforcement
action to make an arrest uh possibly
sees any uh profits that they have from
the sale of counterfeit merchandise and
ultimately the goods are are destroyed a
name brand article from an e-commerce
platform there's a highly high
likelihood that it's probably
counterfeit um if you're purchasing it
from facebook if you're purchasing it
from craigslist those are slam dunks
counterfeits um if you
want a legitimate article uh you should
be going to an authorized reseller of
those products whether it's a big box
store or directly from the mat to the
trademark holder that actually has the
rights to those goods
bottom line is if it sounds too good to
be true it likely is and port director
iman says that selling counterfeit goods
often funds organized crime and
sometimes terrorism brian
thanks angela back to break down this
massive bust of fake jewelry is criminal
defense attorney adam conta and terry
austin terry i know they're going after
the major counterfeiters but can people
be charged for buying fake jewelry
you know you have to be careful it
really does depend under federal law it
makes it illegal to traffic counterfeit
goods and what that means is the
production or the sale or the transport
but they're trying to protect the
trademark so that's why they're doing
that but federal law doesn't prohibit an
individual from buying those counterfeit
goods if you're going to use it for
personal use and most states follow that
same rule if you're buying it and it's
personal use it's not a problem unless
you know about it and you intend to
defraud or sell you can know about it as
long as it's just for personal use all
right adam where do you get your very
real rolex's and how do you think people
can best protect themselves from being
duped
uh i get mine from the diamond district
here in new york city uh you gotta know
i mean you either know a jeweler you
have a relationship with a jeweler that
you know and trust and has been tried
and true over the years or exactly like
you said you know you go to an
authorized reseller uh if you're going
online there are sites like crown and
caliber and other you know watch sites
that will give you sort of a guarantee
so if you find it's fake you can
obviously return it but yeah i mean you
take these you take it and uh you take
your life into your hands with these
with these situations your wallet into
your hands i should say because there's
so many fakes out there but if you do
your research uh you can still find good
deals and still make sure they're
authentic absolutely now and jeanette
what other issues can arise from these
counterfeit goods
well you know part director mons says
oftentimes they're made of materials
that are just not good they're not
suitable
to be around people and there have been
instances of accidents happening or say
you have something a counterfeit piece
of clothing it might be flammable
something like that so
they can pose a hazard to your health
and your safety yeah you know that won't
always happen of course but it can
happen
absolutely i was going to check those
jewelry and make sure that they're
they're proper uh
thank you for everyone for contributing
uh definitely out i'm gonna go check out
your guy in the diamond district coming
up on law and crime and daily back to
the sarah lawrence college sex cult
trial why the defendant was abruptly
rushed from the courtroom plus just
months after foster elizabeth holmes is
convicted her former lover ramif sunny
bowani stands trial in the same
courtroom coming up we head to
california for the federal trial's
opening statements
[Music]
welcome back testimony is now underway
in the federal trial of one-time
theranos c-o-o ramir sunny bhawani after
a brief delay opening statements were
presented in california on tuesday moani
is charged with 10 counts of fraud and
two counts of conspiracy relating to his
role in the failed blood testing company
bowani managed the day-to-day operations
of the company overseeing the testing
lab and was instrumental in the decision
to use modified third-party analyzers
elizabeth holmes founder and ex-lover of
belwani was convicted of three counts of
fraud and one count of conspiracy in
relation to her time with theranos her
sentencing is scheduled for september
the two were indicted together but the
trials were separated after holmes's
accusations of bowani abusing her and
controlling this company bowani's
attorneys have denied these allegations
they claim he did not control their
norse nor did he steal a dollar from the
company the trial is expected to last
for weeks
criminal defense attorney adam costa and
kanta sorry and co-host terry austin are
back as we jump into the first days of
the second weeks-long thera-nose trial
terry on top of this highly publicized
trial the hulu series the dropout was
just released chronicling the rise and
fall of elizabeth holmes are jurors and
witnesses expected to steer clear of
this new show
ryan not only should they steer clear of
it they're expected to do that but the
judge is going to remind them to do that
because they're supposed to only listen
to the evidence in the case that's
presented at the trial the problem with
watching these documentaries is that the
facts begin to blur you start to confuse
did i hear that at the trial or was that
during that documentary the other thing
is the way these shows are produced it
makes the viewer believe what actually
happened if you think about other cases
like r kelly you hear all of that
evidence you see all the people who are
talking about the case and you start to
believe it so you want jurors not to see
that before they come in you want them
to only consider what the evidence is
not even what the lawyers are arguing
and so i think that they're going to
have to stay clear of it and hopefully
they'll be reminded to do exactly that
because there is a sixth amendment right
obviously for the right to a fair trial
for every defendant absolutely no adam
bowani's trial seems to be mirroring
holmeses from witness order to testimony
given does having kind of like a road
map of the trial give belwani an
advantage holmes didn't have
well if when you say the question like
that your initial instinct is yeah of
course you know they got to preview
all that evidence they got to preview
all of the prosecution's arguments
against them and that is true that they
did get to do that but the flip side and
what i think is actually the more
important side is that the prosecution
got to get a preview of what defense is
going to be and even though they might
have separate defenses the defense is
still going to be close enough that they
get to see oh here here are my
weaknesses like as a defense attorney we
hate doing retrials because uh because
the prosecution got to see what they did
wrong the first time and then they get
to plug those holes essentially and so
here although they do get bolani does
have that advantage of previewing the
evidence
i would be really nervous that the
prosecution got to see kind of what
holes along the way
needed to be filled in the holmes trial
and those holes are going to be filled
either by evidence or witnesses so
that's really scary for a defendant too
so it really cuts both ways yeah we'll
see how it goes to your point the
prosecution's probably going to do it a
little bit better they've had some
practice in the past but bowani may be a
little bit more prepared than holmes was
of course we'll keep eyes on that
federal trial as it continues thank you
both when we come back the sarah
lawrence called a sex cult why testimony
was interrupted again as accused cult
leader lawrence ray stands trial
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back a trial in new york takes a
day off as accused sarah lawrence sex
call leader lawrence ray faces federal
charges a day after the defendant was
taken out of the courthouse on a
stretcher this is the second time ray
has been transported to the hospital in
the middle of a trial the first time his
attorney says he was it was because he
suffered a seizure this time no details
were released as to why the ambulance
was called the 62 year old stands
accused of racketeering sex trafficking
and money laundering charges among
others after allegedly starting what the
he calls the rey family in 2010 a sex
cult made up of his daughter and her
college friends jurors have heard
gripping testimony from several of the
victims in this case including the
prosecution's key witness claudia jury
but her testimony has been interrupted
several times prosecutors didn't even
make it through direct examination on
tuesday before court was interrupted by
ray being taken to the hospital jury
testified about rey making her and other
students do hard labor at the home of
rey's stepfather in north carolina she
also said ray had forced her into
prostitution making money for him to the
tune of 2.5 million dollars prosecutors
argue ray used manipulation on the
victims in several ways and used that
fear against them
law and crimes adam classified has been
in the courtroom throughout the
proceedings he joins us now with more
insight into drury's testimony
what would happen typically the
government says is that larry ray would
convince these kids into believing that
they committed these crimes and then
used these confessions to instill this
fear that they're going to go to prison
and once he instilled this sense of fear
and the sense of indebtedness
for these infractions he'd attach a
price tag in the case of drury she says
that she would try to pay back at
larry's suggestion
with sex work and that this went on for
a number of years that it was seven days
a week up to five clients a day and
eventually added up to the million a
bdsm became an outlet being beaten for
her was an outlet because this alleged
psychological manipulation and these
false confessions had just taken a toll
on her sense of self-worth so this was a
period of pretty intense and twisted
psychological manipulation
that prosecutors say really manifested
in a really horrific
stream of abuse against all of these
kids
out of hard labor humiliation and this
psychological coercion seemed to be the
heart of this sex cult do you expect a
doctor testifying about the effects of
this abuse on the victims in this trial
yeah i would be stunned if there wasn't
a doctor everything you just described
is essentially beyond what a normal
juror would be able to understand
meaning that they wouldn't be able to
diagnose although those those things you
can you understand what torture is you
understand uh some of those other things
you need an expert you need a doctor to
really go through and explain
what what happened what the
psychological and medical effects of
some of these things are and uh
and without that you know you're just
you're just kind of just be like you or
me talking with no with no real
background with no real expertise in it
so i think absolutely there will be an
expert and i think it'll be a critical
witness yeah it's bad i don't think
anyone's going to disagree that's bad
but i think with an expert to your point
we know how bad where it's bad and to
the extent of how it affected these
victims terry taken out on a stretcher
again the jury has to be speculating
that something is wrong what do you
think they're thinking and how could it
affect the trial
you know what brian on the one hand the
jury might begin to feel sorry for this
defendant twice now he's been taken out
on a stretcher and we know also that he
had an incident before he actually came
into court early on so he's had three
incidents and you have to wonder is his
illness going to affect the trial is it
going to affect how these jurors feel
about him will they give him extra
sympathy will they relate to him because
they too might have illnesses that
affect how they can function on the
other hand they might get tired of the
trial being constantly interrupted is he
faking it that's one of the things i
think the jury must be thinking is he
doing this to just avoid prosecution
yeah and they seem to be happening when
the victim juries on the stand could be
a part of the speculation well thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
so
[Music]
you